merci d'accueillir Léa Drucker et la
médecine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
bonsoir amen
je voulais juste te dire à Matt que
j'étais très heureuse d'être en ta
compagnie ce soir pour mettre à
l'honneur ensemble
dans les catégories pardon pour mettre à
l'honneur ensemble les nommer dans les
catégories court-métrages de fiction
costume décor et premier film
Ahmed ça va ça va
ça va ah ça va c'est juste que là il y a
ma mère qui regarde et et il y a juste
tout le cinéma français une partie de
l'Amérique
oui mais en même temps t'inquiète pas
toi aussi tu fais du cinéma puis tu as
fait des super films
[Rires]
tous bien habillé et tout regarde ça
c'est impressionnant quoi c'est la
grande famille du cinéma français
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à le dire en italien dis-le
en grec
et mystère
[Musique]